[Music]
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between nandos in the uk and the us
this is food wars
[Music]
okay slight problem nando's is in the
u.s but it's only in four places
maryland illinois virginia and
washington dc
now i'm in l.a baby i'm on the wrong
side of the mississippi
but luckily i have a colleague who is a
nando's enthusiast
in chicago she frequent nando's when she
was living in south africa
and is perfect for taking the us reigns
for this episode of food wars
don't do food wars without eating
breakfast i realize
yeah i've made that mistake several
times
in the uk nando's chicken comes in three
serving sizes
a quarter of a chicken in the u.s
nando's standard chicken comes in just
two sizes there's a half a chicken
a whole chicken or a fourth of a chicken
you can get a whole chicken in the u.s
but only as part of a platter
and we're going to weigh the whole
chicken to see
which country's chickens are bigger usa
chicken baby
we can also get boneless thighs in the
uk if you order these they come in a
portion of four
our thighs actually come as a portion of
three so we got one
two three chicken chicken wings
they're my favorite thing and i'd love
to sing if you haven't already seen it
look up the nando's skank
uh which is a very pure distillation of
british culture in the
late naughties it's ed sheeran and
example wrapping
rapping about nando's in a car park i
don't know why and then
he's just flexing his black card which
i'm feeling about because you know
nando's black card
they give them out to select individuals
and it entitles you to free nando's
which i'm so jealous of
also bone to pick with that in general
why do they always give the celebrities
the free stuff because they're the
people you need at least they're already
rich
sort of guy out come on i'm not a
celebrity
not yet next up in the uk we've got
wings they come in four portions
a portion of three our wings come as a
serving of 12.
a portion of five or a portion of 10
24 or a portion of 15.
if chicken on the bone isn't for you
nando's also offers chicken in the form
of burgers
wraps and pitters in the uk you can get
these as singles
or as doubles we can also get our
chicken
wrapped or burgered
however in the u.s there's no option to
add double chicken
which sucks a little burrito
holy don't do food words without eating
breakfast
i'm going to cry we're going to remove
all the toppings from the single chicken
burger and weigh it to see how it
compares to the us version
so we're going to take out the tomato
and the lettuce
just like harry mentioned
which is good because tomato does not
belong on burgers and never should
on the side of your chicken it's pretty
common to get some chips at nando's i'm
excited for this episode because i can
actually call them chips for once as
that's what they're referred to on the
us menu
suck it joe suck it joel what did i do
why is everyone telling me
he's not even hosting this episode i
just can't
chips in the uk come in regular or large
sizes
the standard us sizes are regular and
large however if you get them as part of
a platter
you can get the bonus extra-large size
let's weigh the large fries to see whose
is bigger
maybe i should have used the bowl oh no
i'm still gonna eat these i don't care
if they touch all these
gross
i'm getting too good at emptying brick
chips from containers
so our scale is just about adequate for
this one and a portion of large fries in
the uk
i said fries why do i say fries i'm
being conditioned to selling fries
that's right buddy i heard you say fries
sure is getting to me
a portion of large chips in the uk comes
to about 498 grams 150 grams
what about the biggest thing on each
country's menu well in the uk it's this
the family platter
it comes with two whole chickens five
large sides and will cost you 43 pounds
and 70 pence
the biggest us item is the jumbo platter
it includes two whole chickens with two
extra-large sides for 52.99
let's take a look at some of the
nutritional standouts from the nando's
menu if you were to get a standard meal
it might look something like this
half a chicken a portion of perry salted
chips and a portion of macho peas in the
uk this would come to a total of 1228
calories which honestly isn't too bad
there's also nothing really alarming on
that the only notable thing is that it
contains 186.4
of your daily protein intake over here
it comes out to 124
calories which is actually a little less
than the uk's version
our chicken and chips are actually a
little less calorific than the uk's
but for some reason our macho peas are
more calorific
what's this dish
already i can tell there's a bunch of
like spices
and seasoning on the peas i'm thinking
butter is involved
oh i hate peas that is not what i was
expecting
it does have a kick to it based on the
ingredients there's not really anything
alarming
that we see in the u.s version either
there's just a lot of sodium in it which
is kind of expected because of all the
spices and the seasoning that goes into
it
one thing to watch out for is the
basting flavor of your chicken
somehow if you get your chicken as extra
hot in the u.s it adds
4 611 milligrams of sodium
that's double your daily allowance just
for the baste
that's so much sodium that's insane what
about the most calorific thing on the uk
menu well it might not surprise you to
learn that it's actually a whole chicken
extra hot is also the least healthy
based in the uk with an extra hot hole
chicken coming in at 1
299 calories however a whole chicken
actually isn't the most calorific thing
on the menu in the us
this is the nandoka's choice burger
which is a butterfly chicken breast
and coleslaw in between garlic bread
buns
dude a burger with garlic bread for a
bun that sounds
so good that is a genius idea send me
that
one of these comes at 1003 calories
it looks like the main culprit here is
the garlic bread buns
on the us menu the garlic bread is the
most
calorific regular side and it's the
highest
cholesterol side as well
[Applause]
i kinda wanna try it
it's not what you would expect it's not
like u.s garlic bread
that's a little strange as the uk's most
calorific side is actually the perry
salted chips
these come in at 519 calories whereas
the garlic bread is only 362.
what are you guys doing to your garlic
bread i think we're just making our
garlic bread tastier
it feels like you're trying to attack me
harry trying to attack the u.s
we don't like that while the garlic
bread may be high in cholesterol
it pales in comparison to one item in
that area
which is the chicken livers one serving
of these
contain 978 milligrams of cholesterol
comfortably the highest thing on the
menu more than
triple your daily recommended amount uk
nando's don't disclose cholesterol
content but they do distort fat content
the fattiest thing on the menu is once
again the whole chicken one of these
contains 54.4 grams of fat which is
around 69
of your daily allowance nice nice
nice nice okay
unfortunately nanos doesn't disclose a
full ingredients list in the uk
same here all we get are allergens and
the allergen list doesn't contain
anything
too alarming we reached out to nando's
for more information about the
ingredients
they told us that all their chicken
meets or exceeds usda quality standards
and is never frozen they also grow their
own african bird's eye chilies on farms
across south africa
for an authentic peri-peri spice one
piece of information you can get from
the uk's faq page is that the
plant-based
great imitator wrap might not actually
be as plant-based as it seems
the based and the tortilla wrap used
both contain shellac now shellac is also
sometimes called confectioner's glaze
and it's a natural polymer that's used
to
give things a waxy finish and to trap in
moisture but where does shellac actually
come from
well it's actually secreted by female
lac beetles onto
trees in india and thailand this means
it's technically an animal product and
although it can be gathered without
harming the beetles
this is hard to achieve in practice not
nice it's worth pointing out one other
faq from the uk page
which is that the uk nando's have
explicitly committed to never using
chlorinated chicken from america
chlorinated chicken's been in the
headlines a lot recently because it's
kind of become the face of differing
food standards between the uk and the us
it refers to the process of giving
slaughter chickens a chemical wash
before they're packaged and sent to
consumers
what do you guys have against our
chlorinated chicken
jake you're gonna see oh there's so many
things against our chlorine chicken
this is done to kill harmful bacteria
like salmonella
even the european union admits that it's
unlikely to pose any health risks to
consumers
but campaigners say that it also allows
farmers to cover up lower production
standards throughout the chicken rearing
process
the good news is that it's estimated
only 10
of us chicken actually gets treated with
chlorine
so it's not a guarantee that nando's
chicken in the u.s will have been
through the process
but it's an interesting example of the
different food standards in the uk
and the us chicken tastes pretty good
over here so
it is what it is
here is everything you will only find on
the menu at uk nando's and here's
everything
you can only find on the menu at a us
nando's
let's start with some chicken options
here we got the sunset burger which is
currently i believe exclusive to
delivery platforms
this is a soft roll and then it also
contains chicken thighs
cheddar cheese red pepper chutney mayo
and lettuce next up we've got chicken
wing roulette now what this is is 10
chicken wings of varying spice levels
the idea i guess is that you order a
plate of these for yourself and your
friends
you all pick one or two and the loser
gets blasted with some extra hot sauce
now obviously we have to try this
ourselves so myself and our camera
person laura
are going to give this a go and see who
loses now i think we are all right
okay that one looks yeah you're you're
going dangerous i'm going for like a
menacingly red one yes you are i'm going
for the less menacing looking one
hopefully it's a red herring with dennis
to deceive you cheers cheers
absolutely fine it was okay yeah it's
spicy
it's not like blowing my head off i feel
like mine's maybe
hot but if that's extra hot though i'm
like very underwhelmed slight
anti-climax i think laura maybe just got
like a medium or a plain one because she
was not faced at all
i think maybe i got like hot if that was
extra hot i'm very disappointed all i
say
a little cocky there buddy so i got
myself a bottle of the
nando's peripery xx hot sauce and i too
want to try
the spiciest level that they offer okay
that might have been too much
that's extra hot huh no i'm very strong
i like the flavor a lot on that but wait
um definitely manageable yeah i mean
like i love the flavor of all this stuff
this is not that hot
now for those of you who think i got off
lightly and actually want to see me in
pain you're in luck because in the uk
we have an exclusive spice level that
goes above extra hot here we have three
chicken wings coated in
vusa xx sauce which is one level above
extra hot on the nando's periometer
now these already look hotter than
anything that was in the roulette box
there's lots of chilli
flakes on them that are visible and it's
just that kind of like alarming red
color that if you see a snake that color
you're supposed to run away from
some sticks are friendly grass snakes
grass snakes are cool
and of course because i hate myself i'm
going to try one of these
they didn't give us gloves like they did
in the wingstop episode
which i guess is a good sign i'm not
great with spice so let's see how this
goes
is that the slow burn there's a really
slow bam
not really getting much from this i'll
be honest maybe if i just rub my eyes
i'm not really getting it that's
disappointing i like to say i'm not good
with spice
but i'm handling that with ease nando's
come on it would have made for better
content if you made me cry guys
so it's about the same as what i got
from there y'all tried your really
hot wings right well i just wanted a
taste of the
the hot sauce that they provided us with
here if i can
get it open at any point in my life
nando's peri-peri sauce hot gluten free
excuse me
committing
[Laughter]
i should get an oscar
it was a little hot but it wasn't like
too hot that i'm dying it's kind of
spicy
but this already has i did that trick
did you see how it became a double agent
wow i actually did have a reaction no
it's really sweet
it just hits you in the throat it's like
on the other end of the heat scale from
vusa we have one more exclusive based
which is the peritamer this is described
as mild and sweet and it's just for
people who don't really like spice
and then finally we have something that
isn't technically chicken but more of a
chicken replacement this is the great
imitator wrap
it contains imitation chicken made from
pea protein so we have some exclusive
chicken items of our own harry we can
get these
chicken size skewers which come with red
pepper
and onions and they look salivating
we can also get these chicken livers
which you won't currently find
on the uk menu due to the pandemic the
thigh and mighty sandwich then we can
get a chicken caesar in the form of a
wrap
or a pita bread also got a lot of salad
bowls
and that you won't find in the uk
there's a
peri-peri chicken tender bowl an ancient
grains bowl a chicken caesar
salad a tomato and halloumi salad
and chicken and avocado and pepper
roasted bowl
and a cauliflower butternut
and halloumi salad it's just like a lot
of salad
that's not my cup of tea this is my cup
of tea
we have two exclusive appetizers in the
uk firstly we have
halloumi sticks with a chili jam dip
and then we have some sweet potato
wedges which are served with a
garlic perrinase i do not like sweet
potato i wish people would stop serving
on menus it is always worse than chips
and always costs more
so we only get the one exclusive
appetizer the garlic sticks
on the side of your meal in the uk we
have a few exclusive sides such as corn
on the cob
some long stem broccoli spicy rice
and finally we have some coleslaw our
exclusive sides are a caesar side salad
portuguese rice winter roasted veggies
butternut squash
and corn in braised brussels sprouts now
in addition to the vusa sauce we also
have garlic perennials as i mentioned
which comes with the sweet potato wedges
and we have this one which is a peri
barbecue sauce the only exclusive sauce
we have is a coconut lemon perry perry
sauce
it will take a while to go through all
of the exclusive drinks so we're just
going to show you some highlights such
as this this is a
gingerella which is an organic ginger
ale nyx and kicks sparkling cucumber
mint drink with a hint of cayenne and of
course
we have this one which is a royal flush
kombucha now i personally like kombucha
i know it's a little bit divisive
but it's pretty good we can also get
alcohol from the uk nando's got some
lager some pilsner an ipa
and a white wine and bundaberg
ginger beer this honest iced tea
as well as a mexican coke which
throw me the bottle opener we also got
alcohol too
we got beer wine we can get rose sangria
and spiked lemonade
nice and our only exclusive dessert
option
is this barely baked brownie let's
finish out with the desserts
in the uk you can close out your meal
with a slice of chocolate cake
which is really good it's very moist
with a slice of white chocolate and
raspberry cheesecake
and finally a gooey caramel cheesecake i
thought i'd have a crack at explaining
the whole cheeky nando's phenomenon to
our viewers from across the pond
if you were on the internet like five or
ten years ago you've probably seen this
phrase
it just kind of refers to this time
where cheeky nandos with the lads was
just the go-to activity
it's like mostly teenage boys would go
into town for a day out
wander around the shops end up in
nando's have a meal and then usually
instagram or snapchat
with the caption cheeky nando's with the
lads with this emoji
i'm going to make that my next instagram
caption
cheeky nanders with the lads clancy's my
lad
come here clancy
cheeky nando's at the lads chicken and
chips
carrie you gotta bust a move more
yeah no thanks on that guys and no
thanks
that's quite enough of that chicken
wings
they're my favorite thing and i love to
sing all right
another food wars episode where i did
almost nothing
i could get used to this